in den letzten Jahren die
Produktionsstraßen bei deutschen
Automobilbauern still gestanden haben
dann nicht wegen corona-regeln oder so
sondern weil wir halbleitermangel hatten
die nicht nachgekommen sind und daher
die Autos nicht vom Band laufen konnten
das heißt wir sind hier in dem Bereich
den wir bei unserer China und anderen
Politik mit die risking beschreiben wir
müssen uns in Deutschland halten Abbauen
von Komponenten die wir überwiegend
heute aus dem internationalen Raum holen
und die unsere Leitindustrie und wie die
Automobilindustrie und andere ganz
dringend brauchen wir haben bereits Chip
industrieschwerpunkt bei Dresden im
Silicon sexy wir werden es jetzt bei
Magdeburg haben übrigens spannend die
haben das in mehreren Dutzend Standorten
in Europa geprüft Intel und haben sich
für Magdeburg entschieden weil dort
erneuerbare Energien in großer Zahl
vorhanden sind und weil dort
leitungsinfrastruktur ist das also auch
wirklich dorthin kommt schöne Grüße zu
Herrn Söder nach Bayern dort siedelt
sich so ein Unternehmen im Moment nicht
an weil das dort nämlich nicht
funktioniert im Moment insofern ist das
schon interessant zu sehen